partie du deuxième groupe d'astronautes
européens du mans voyez aussitôt à la
nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est commun dans
une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale
malgré des tensions
à la surface de noter m
[Musique]
un professeur d'histoire décapité en
pleine rue pour avoir osé montrer des
caricatures du prophète à ses élèves
l'enseignant du collège de
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines a été tuée au couteau par un
homme devant son établissement scolaire
l'assaillant a été abattu par les forces
de l'ordre le parquet antiterroriste est
saisie
[Musique]
plus que quelques heures avant l'entrée
en vigueur du couvre-feu dans plusieurs
villes de france à partir de minuit sauf
exception personne ne pourra circuler
dans les rues entre 21h et 6h du matin
là pas d'exception pour le secteur
culturel a précisé le premier ministre
depuis l'île et pas de primes non plus
pas de prime exceptionnelle pour les
bénéficiaires des aides au logement
comme pourtant promis par emmanuel
macron le premier ministre britannique
qui appelle ses concitoyens à se
préparer à un odile sur le break 6 à 10
semaines de la sortie du marché commun
toujours aucun compromis sur un éventuel
accord commercial avec l'union
européenne
boris johnson estime que les
négociations sont terminées à moins d'un
changement fondamental de la part des
vingt-sept à paris accuse londres de
vouloir faire de la concurrence déloyale
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi un homme
décapité en pleine rue il ya quelques
heures le parquet antiterroriste est
saisie selon la police la personne est
gorgé est un professeur d'histoire au
collège de conflans sainte honorine
le 5 octobre dernier cet enseignant
aurait montré ou fait allusion en tout
cas aux caricatures de mahomet celles
qui ont conduit aux massacres des
journalistes de charlie hebdo il a été
attaqué aux alentours de 17h
l'assaillant a ensuite pris la fuite
la police municipale a donné l' alerte
puis la brigade anti criminalité s'est
aussitôt rendu sur place
elle a retrouvé l'homme muni d'un
couteau qui aurait alors menacé les
policiers et après plusieurs sommations
les policiers ont tiré sur le forcené il
a succombé à ses tirs pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec alexis
poulain éditorialiste politique et rt
france
bonsoir alexis poulain merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france on le
sait maintenant c'est un professeur
d'histoire qui a été décapitée devant
son collège pour avoir montré des
caricatures de mahomet quelle est votre
réaction ce soir
la sidération la colère le fait de dire
que c'est un professeur qui faisait son
travail qui avait donc dans un court
sujet sur la laïcité a montré ses
caricatures à ses élèves en demandant
d'ailleurs aux élèves musulmans de
quitter la salle si il était choqué ça
c'est ce que j'ai pu lire sur comment ça
s'était passé à quelques semaines mais
ça avait malheureusement choqué et le
voilà qui aujourd'hui se fait décapiter
par un terroriste qui pense agir au nom
de son dieu et qui décapite ceux qui
osent montrer des caricatures du
prophète
alors j'aimerais d'abord penser à la
famille de cet enseignant décédé c'est
terrible à ses élèves à ce collège de
contenants extractives itie moment
d'envoyer merci contre l'enceinte en
haïti vit ces moments terribles
et rappeler qu'on est en france qu'on
est une république laïque et qu'on a le
droit de caricaturer de rire des
religions de montrer des caricatures du
prophète que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe ici
je suis content que gérald darmanin et
écourté son séjour au maroc et qu'il
rentre de toute urgence
il va peut-être falloir faire quelque
chose pour se protéger davantage de ce
genre de personnages qui sont une menace
endémique et sur la vie des personnes et
sur la liberté d'expression et sur la
laïcité dans notre pays et comment
comment protéger alors ces personnes qui
défendent la liberté d'expression on se
souvient qu emmanuel macron avait dit
qu'il y avait un droit au blasphème
on se souvient aussi de la tacc près des
locaux de charlie hebdo de ce
pakistanais qui pensait s'en prendre à
des journalistes du journal
la menace est toujours là ça veut dire
que les gens vont avoir peur maintenant
de faire allusion à ses caricatures ou à
tout autre chose d'ailleurs mais c'est
bien l'idée c'est bien l'idée de ces
terroristes ins et de terroriser les
populations et de faire que petit à
petit nos libertés soient soient
réduites et qu'il gagne le combat et
d'ailleurs je ne sais plus quel ministre
avait dit il faut terroriser les
terroristes je me sens là charles pasqua
s'était lui mais en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence oui le seul langage que ces
gens connaissent c'est la terreur qui
répondra à la terreur et malheureusement
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
certaine complaisance ou du moins nous
ne sommes pas armés pour répondre à
cette menace le nombre des attaques au
couteau ne fait qu'empirer sur le
territoire français mais sur le sol
européen en général
le nombre de ces profils de ces gens qui
se réclament de l'islam et qui agissent
au nom d'un dieu pour décapiter et tué
des personnes généralement les religions
sont plutôt là pour préserver la vie et
faire en sorte que on évite ce genre de
bain de sang mais apparemment non pas
pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui on n'a pas les réponses on a
bien sûr un fichier des fichiers s on a
un certain nombre de personnes qui sont
suivis par la police on a aujourd'hui
dans les prisons françaises un nombre de
radicaliser qui sont en prison mais qui
sont prêtes à sortir ou qui vont bientôt
sortir
on n'a pas vraiment
l'outil pour faire en sorte que ces gens
là soit éloigné du territoire c'était
l'idée de manuel valls qui avait été
largement critiqué la déchéance de
nationalité mais qui pose question quant
au profil de ses attaquants de ces
djihadistes de l'intérieur de ces gens
qui sont prêts à tuer contre la liberté
d'expression contre notre mode de vie et
qui reste au sein de la société une
menace et qui théorisent l'ensemble de
la société et le problème est là c'est
que derrière nous devons répondre dans
le cadre de l'état de droit et
heureusement nous sommes un état de
droit nous n'avons plus la peine de mort
nous avons le droit au blasphème
heureusement nous avons toute cette
liberté une grande et historique
démocratie tant mieux mais nous devons
utiliser ce droit là et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que l'état d'urgence se
prolonge pour d'autres choses nous
coronavirus vigipirate qui était
instaurée il ya quelques années est
toujours là et toujours dans la zone
rouge
alors on a monté petit à petit les lois
d'exception qui sont rentrés dans le
droit commun pour lutter contre le
terrorisme mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour ce genre de profil qui peut passer
à l'acte n'importe quand avec un hachoir
de boucher ou un couteau malheureusement
alors là il y avait quand même des
signes alarmants puisque ce les
caricatures aurait été montré aux élèves
le 5 octobre dernier des parents se
serait plaint justement de ces
agissements de ce professeur ne
fallait-il pas le mettre sous protection
dès lors c'est tout le problème c'est
qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas mettre
sous protection toute la population tous
les gens qui font qu'ils usent de leur
droit de parole qu'il use de la liberté
de parole
là on est dans un moment où on a peur de
parler parce que parler de caricature
même ça vous met en danger même faire de
l'humour sur la religion vous met en
danger
donc on ne peut pas demander à la police
d'être derrière tous les citoyens qui
vivent librement dans un pays libre
c'est bien c'est bien le problème que je
relevais tout à l'heure c'est
qu'aujourd'hui est ce que la police a
les moyens de protéger la population de
ces profs qui l'a visiblement non et oui
même si ce professeur avait peut-être
reçu des menaces de mort il ya une
semaine de cela quand il avait commencé
à faire cours ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que ces menaces allait être mise
à exécution mais il ya beaucoup comme ça
de menaces de mort quotidiennement et le
problème c'est que maintenant les gens
passent à l'acte c'est qu'on est rentré
dans un moment où il n'y a plus besoin
d'une vaste opération d'envergure avec
un support terroristes qui viendrait de
syrie ou d'ailleurs d'al qaïda ou de
dèche simplement avec un couteau et l
envie de tuer quelqu'un on peut le faire
au nom d'une religion et de manière
extrêmement sauvage comme on l'a vu ce
soir malheureusement vous avez prononcé
le mot gérald darmanin avait parlé dans
sauvagement de la société des mots qui
prennent encore plus leur sens
aujourd'hui
oui alors ce sont des mots qui
traditionnellement appartenait à
l'extrême droite et je les utilise et
parfois on me renvoie en fait la
critique mais comment qualifier cet acte
de cet homme qui décide de tuer un
professeur d'histoire géographie qui
faisait simplement son travail quand on
tue quelqu'un parce qu'on refuse de
débattre avec lui parce qu'on refuse ces
idées parce qu'on refuse son mode de vie
on est dans la sauvagerie on est dans le
lentilles civilisationnel c'est un rejet
total de ce qui fait notre société donc
je ne vois pas quel pourrait être votre
bon alors c'est malheureux que on pense
que ce soit un mot de kiki et une
connotation politique particulière il y
as derrière une réalité sur la violence
globale de notre société telle qu'elle
est en train d'être vu et le fait que
des individus comme le tueur de ce soir
passent à l'acte sans même se poser une
seule fois la question de ce que c'est
que tu es un être humain et c'est ça moi
qui m'inquiète c'est de voir comment
c'est devenu facile facile en fait de
frapper de mutiler d'être violent avec
quelqu'un d'autre de tu jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'au meurtre
sans se poser la question c'est le cas
du meurtre de victorine on ne sait pas
encore tout à fait tous les motifs mais
visiblement ça part d'une dispute et
puis on va jusqu'à tuer la personne en
face mais qui sont ces gens ces
psychopathes qui sont dans nos rues qui
sont qui ont grandi avec nous qui sont
là aujourd'hui qu'ils sont incapables de
vivre en société c'est ça moi qui me
fait vraiment peur c'est de voir ce
moment où oui
la société est devenue d'une extrême
violence et donc d'une certaine
sauvagerie puisque la règle de la nature
c'est la loi du plus fort est donc celui
qui a un couteau peut tuer parce qu'on
ne doit pas se défendre on n'est pas
habitué à ce genre de
d'actes ce genre de comportement vous
l'avez dit le professeur d'histoire
décédé avait demandé aux élèves
musulmans de quitter la salle
ça montre qu'il ya un certain malaise
certains diront qu'il a fait preuve de
provocation également comment n'ont-ils
justement il n'a pas assez de preuve de
provocation il a demandé aux élèves
musulmans de quitter la salle avant de
montrer ses caricatures on est dans le
cadre d'un nouvel de demander à des
élèves de quitter la salle quand on fait
un court si c'est parce qu il nous
montrait les caricatures et justement
qu'il voulait éviter ce genre de drame
en disant je ne veux pas vous choqué par
ce que je vais montrer ses caricatures
si vous ne voulez pas les voir vous avez
droit de sortir il est tout à fait dans
le cadre de son métier et dans le cadre
républicain de la laïcité où il ne va
pas offenser des élèves musulmans en
leur montrant de force des caricatures
donc là en plus il faisait un très bon
boulot je vois pas où est le problème
et oui il a le droit de dire aux
musulmans sortie si vous voulez pas voir
les caricatures mais qu'on fasse
voilà qu'ils se fassent tuer pour ça et
que le message derrière soi de le dire
vous n'aurez pas le droit d'organiser
des débats dans les écoles de france sur
la laïcité sur ce qu'est le cas les
caricatures sur ce qu'est enfin voilà le
droit au blasphème enfin le fait
d'organiser le débat c'est voilà c'est
interdire la parole interdire le débat
interdire à ces gens qui pourraient
s'ouvrir qui pourrait dialoguer et bien
les pousser dans des retranchements
parce que ces terroristes la dhr refuse
qu'on puisse vivre comme on l'a toujours
fait dans la liberté et dans le respect
de l'autre et ça c'est insupportable
emmanuel macron qui est aussitôt s'est
rendu à la place beauvau justement pour
faire un point de la situation
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre justement
du discours politique après un tel
événement bien on va sans doute voir un
renforcement des mesures d'exception on
était déjà dans le cadre de la loi sur
le séparatisme islamique donc si ce
crime est motivé et ça semble être le
cas par part par des arrière pensées
islamistes terroristes
ce sera le cas donc gérard damas l'un va
se dérouler sur cette thématique du
séparatisme et puis les questions qui se
poseront sur les moyens de protection
les moyens du renseignement aujourd'hui
la direction générale du rance
iman intérieur et saisi la direction
antiterroriste de la police nationale
également la question va se poser deux
mais combien de profil de ce genre là
sont aujourd'hui dans la nature est prêt
à passer à l'acte comment faire pour se
protéger de ces terroristes de
l'intérieur comment faire pour vivre
continuer d'avoir cette liberté de
parole qui fait la république parce que
au-delà de ce meurtre il 2 2 ce soir il
y à toute une bataille qui se fait dans
la sphère publique que ce soit sur les
réseaux sociaux ou ailleurs sur les gens
qui prennent position contre cette
branche radicale d'une religion qui
pousse au crime et où c'est interdit de
dire des choses pareilles où on voudrait
pour le respect tout ce qu'on recompte
ça se passait débat justement mais on
doit avoir ses débats on doit pouvoir
vivre librement et pouvoir dire ce qu'on
veut dans ce pays
tant qu'on est dans le respect du droit
et de la loi et qu'on n'est pas ni dans
l'incitation à la haine raciale ni dans
le racisme et ce n'était pas le cas de
ce professeur
et bien c'est ça qui aujourd'hui est
menacée par ces actes de terrorisme du
quotidien qui ne font que s'amplifier
sont multipliés et qui évidemment nous
inquiète au plus haut point où tous tous
les citoyens qui se veut respectueux et
des musulmans dans leur foi et je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui devrait
choquer et qui choque la plupart des
musulmans de france qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ces gestes là et
c'est important de le rappeler ces gens
là sont des dangereux criminels points
n'ont rien à voir avec une parole
particulière ils sont là pour terroriser
de manière politique et parce que voilà
c'est quelque chose qui moi me dépasse
de voir comment on peut ne pas respecter
la personne humaine à ce point là merci
beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce soir sur rtl france
et on poursuit avec justement en direct
le maire d'eragny sur oise c'est dans
cette ville que l'assaillant a été
neutralisé par les forces de l'ordre il
a commis son acte à conflans sainte
honorine puis a pris la fuite et a
finalement été neutralisé par balles
après avoir menacé les forces de l'ordre
on va on va écouter le maire d'eragny
sur oise bonsoir monsieur merci beaucoup
d'être au téléphone avec nous sur rt
france
votre réaction tout d'abord à ce qui
s'est passé sur votre commune
c'est une réaction bonsoir tout d'abord
c'est une réaction
évidemment d'indignation de
consternation est évidemment de révolte
par rapport à 7,7 cet acte ce drame qui
s'est produit chez sécher mes collègues
à conflans sainte honorine et qui s'est
terminée de la façon dont vous savez sur
la ville d'eragny mais ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est l'intervention très
rapide des forces de l'ordre qui ont
réussi à neutraliser l'individu à 400 ou
500 mètres de son effet voilà eragny sur
oise c'est une petite commune qui se
situe à à combien de kilomètres de
conflans sainte honorine
on est limitrophe donc voilà on est c
dimitrov donc on est vraiment 5 semble
là je vous dis là l'individu a été
neutralisé à 500 m 2 de conflans sainte
honorine
sait on est vraiment c'est des communes
limitrophes on est limitrophe est
confiant avec le département des
yvelines
nous on se trouve dans le dans le val
d'oise en 95 et donc voilà donc c'est
c'est moi ce que je suis quand même
souhaité souligner c'est quand même la
très grande rapidité avec les laquelle
les forces de l'ordre ont réagi vous
êtes rendus sur place vous même où on
pèse encore sur place vous ciel sur
place à deux cuillères situation
non non non non non non non non je peux
assister à son interpellation qui sait
de toute façon ils n'ont pu être
réalisés mais neutralisé avec leurs
armes à ce donc
aujourd'hui l'individu est décédé à le
l'auteur de cet acte ignoble est décédé
donc moi je suis arrivé parce que j'ai
été prévenu dix minutes après cinq
minutes routine et après que les coups
de feu étaient attirés et entendu parler
la population et des toisons aider des
témoins sur place qui ont vu la scène
comment cet individu a été neutralisée
est ce que vous pouvez vous nous donner
des précisions
je n'ai je n'ai pas parce que je vais
les gens sont mes concitoyens sont
bloqués chez eux donc je n'ai pas eu pu
parler avec avec les des voisins qui
sont près de cette scène voilà donc
aujourd'hui je le dois au moment où je
vous parle je ne suis pas s'il ya eu des
témoins qui ont vu comment était
neutralisée le le terroriste nous te
dire voilà c'est est ce qu'on aura des
informations sur cette personne est ce
que c'était quelqu'un de la commune non
pas du tout non non pas du tout c'était
quelqu'un de dexter extérieur en tout
cas à votre manie tout à fait
et j'imagine le choc de deux veaux de
vos administrés ce soir bah oui c'est
ccc on y tient un choc un choc et moi en
tant que tony magi phare de la ville en
effet c'est un choc
c'est en deux temps dans une vie de mère
dans notre mission c'est vraiment ce
genre de 2,2 de drame
bien on souhaite que ça n'arrive jamais
et je suis j'ai pas de mots ce soir pour
tomber que tu mets toi ici mais ce que
je sais ce que je ressens tellement
tellement cet acte est ignoble ignoble
je pense à la famille de cette victime
il ya voilà ça c'est très très dur
ce professeur était étaient connus dont
je connaissais pas non non au nom
puisqu'il est il enseigné aux au collège
du bois donne donc à conflans sainte
honorine donc non je ne connaissais pas
l'émulation le fait que ce professeur
est montré des caricatures de mahomet
quel est votre sentiment en tant
qu'homme politique
comment la liberté d'expression je pense
que justement est bas il a voulu
certainement je ne juge peut pas savoir
ce que quelle était sa motivation
première je pense que ça partait
justement pour on au collège chez des
jeunes dans le dans le contexte dans
lequel on évolue depuis envie depuis
2015 c'était certainement une volonté de
d'ouverture d'esprit et de décidé
d'expliquer aujourd'hui que la liberté
d'expression c'est une valeur de notre
de notre pays
très clairement donc pour moi
mais encore une fois je peux pas juger
comment ça a été fait je ne connais pas
j'espère d'information là dessus donc je
me permettrais pas de juger sur la
volonté pédagogique de tutu professeur
ça va nécessiter un l'ouverture d'une
cellule psychologique les élèves auront
du mal en tout cas j'imagine à faire
face à ce drame
ben alors ça c'est mon collègue le rend
proche qui pourra certainement plus vous
dire mon collègue maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine
moi je là dessus en effet s'il ya des
témoins en plus messi et surtout pour
les élèves de ce professeur je pense
qu'il y aura besoin d'une d'une cellule
psychologique comme 17h sortir des
classes avec la wii bas certainement
certains noms j'en sais pas plus
imbattable à la dessus je n'en sais pas
plus pour aider des bêtises
merci beaucoup en tout cas alors répondu
à nos questions en direct ce soir sur
rtl france et on va faire le point à
présent sur place pour rejoindre notre
reporter pierre pissavy yvernault
bonsoir pierre vous êtes sur place
que se passe-t-il autour de vous la
police c'est évidemment sur place
ouais effectivement magali la police est
sur place
comme vous le voyez sur les images de
robin dubois déjà un
gros gros dispositif de sécurité ici à
eragny vous le voyez dans le fond de
cette rue beaucoup de deux camions de
police beaucoup de camions de pompiers
on ne peut pas aller à plus loin pour
l'instant
l'occasion pour moi de vous faire un
petit rappel de ce qui est arrivé ici
cet après midi c'était aux alentours de
17 heures un homme a été retrouvé
décapité dans la commune voisine de
conflans sainte honorine près d'un
établissement scolaire comme l'a dit
votre invité il ya il ya quelques
instants
c'est la bac est qui et qui est arrivé
rapidement qui a été avertie qui t'avait
vite sur place qui a fait face à
l'assaillant l'assaillant qui avait un
couteau à la main alors la back à
traditionnelle fait les
traditionnellement fait les injonctions
de de routine l'homme n'a pas déposé son
couteau il aurait été abattu de
plusieurs balles dans le corps
et puis à la suite de ça c'est le
parquet antiterroriste qui a été saisie
très rapidement pour assassinats en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
et association de malfaiteurs concernant
le gouvernement gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur était en
déplacement au maroc aujourd'hui à dès
qu'il a appris l'information il a bien
sûr pris l'avion direction paris d'après
nos informations il serait déjà arrivé
dans la capitale
il ne va pas venir ici mais il ne sera à
place beauvau au ministère de
l'intérieur pour suivre cette affaire de
la cellule de crise en compagnie
d'autres ministres notamment et sa
ministre délégué
marlène schiappa voilà et puis un mot
également sur la victime
il s'agirait d'un professeur d'histoire
indue du collège juste à côté de là on
l'a retrouvé il aurait montré des
caricatures du prophète mahomet à ses
élèves lors d'un cours justement sur la
liberté d'expression
et puis on l'a appris il
à quelques instants c'est le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron qui est en route
qui devrait arriver dans la soirée du
côté de conflans sainte honorine et de
et de annie voilà tout ce qu'on peut
vous dire pour l'instant ici merci
beaucoup pierre pour toutes ces
précisions on va suivre évidemment au
cours de cette soirée le déroulement de
ce drame
cet après midi donc aux alentours de 17
heures un professeur d'histoire et
gorges et décapité par un homme qui a
été neutralisé par les forces de l'ordre
l'émotion est évidemment sur place mais
dans la classe politique française
voyez ces quelques réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux ce sont des moeurs
médiévale qui s'installe peu à peu dans
notre pays
la douce france n'est plus horrible
décapitation à conflans en pleine rue
d'un enseignant qui aurait montré en
cours des caricatures de mahomet la
barbarie islamiste s'abat sur la france
quand l'état bougera t-il enfin contre
cette peste pensée pour la victime et sa
famille un cours sur la liberté
d'expression et les caricatures conduit
à une décapitation en pleine rue
ça n'est pas un coup de folie le
terrorisme islamiste tu le séparatisme
islamistes doit être combattu sans
relâche sans jamais faiblir
la réponse pénale doit être maximale
ignoble crime à conflans en fait
l'assassin se prend pour le dieu dont il
se réclame
il s'allie sa religion et il nous
inflige à tous l'enfer de devoir vivre
avec les meurtriers de son espèce
1 une attaque en tout cas qui intervient
alors que se tient depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant le procès des
attentats de janvier 2015 des
journalistes de charlie hebdo qui
avaient été ciblés justement à cause de
la publication de ces caricatures de
mahomet on fait le point justement sur
cette 34e journée d'audition à la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris avec katia
pique nique une journée tendue
aujourd'hui au tribunal pour les
attentats de janvier 2015 une enquêtrice
de la sous direction antiterroriste est
venu évoquer la garde à vue d'aleri
zappos lattes
le principal accusé dans ce dossier il
est suspecté d'avoir été le bras droit
dames et 10 coulibaly elle a dressé le
portrait d'un homme radicaliser on a
retrouvé une prestation d'allégeance à
l'état islamique dans une tablette il
aurait voulu se rendre en syrie
juste après les attentats de son côté
ali riza paula proteste il explique
qu'il n'a rien à voir avec tout cela
qu'il n'était pas au courant du projet
terroriste et qu'il avait juste une
dette à rembourser à mehdi coulibaly
d'où les trafics qui leur est fait avec
lui mais il a également le verbe et où
il s'énerve très souvent et à un moment
l'enquêtrice a parlé de sa mère a dit
qu'il l'avait traité de mécréante lors
d'un appel téléphonique alors ali riza
paulette est sorti de ses gonds il a dit
tu vas payer
je vous propose d'écouter isabelle
coûtant peyre son avocate à ce sujet
autant officiellement les juges
d'instruction doivent instruire à charge
ou à décharge
c'est rarement des chargements fin
officiellement c'est leur obligation que
les tribunaux doivent être impartiaux
par contre les policiers
ils n'ont aucune obligation sur ce plan
or dans cette affaire n'est quand même
quelque chose assez extraordinaire c'est
que je rappelle à nouveau les armes qui
ont servi à commettre ces crimes sont
identifiés tout de suite et on a un
policier qui vient nous faire des
rapports sur une espèce de filières de
bricolage de vieilles armes en belgique
avec tout un tas de gens comme
l'expliquent m coûtant peyre
l'enquêtrice de l'as date a passé un
long moment à décrire une filière
d'armes entre différents protagonistes
dans le box il se trouve que ces armes
rouillé et bien il met à mehdi coulibaly
n'en voulait plus certaines ont fini
dans la meuse certains d'autres ont été
revendus mais la véritable filière
d'armin celles qui ont servi à l'hyper
cacher et bien sûr cette filière là il
reste encore de très nombreuses zones
d'ombré et c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale consacrée à cet acte terroriste
qui a été commis à conflans sainte
honorine
aujourd'hui un professeur d'une de
collèges pardon décapité en pleine rue
pour avoir osé montrer des caricatures
du prophète mahomet à ses élèves la
semaine dernière l'enseignant du collège
de conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines a été tué à l'armé blanche
l'assaillant a pris la fuite il a été
rattrapé
vous le voyez sur ces images par la
police et a battu après dé plusieurs
sommations
on va y revenir bien sûr longuement le
parquet antiterroriste d'ailleurs a été
saisie
on revient sur cette information
principale dans une demi heure dans
notre prochain journal
restez avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme
tout est passé